c'est l'événement de ce week-end à tours
la statue de saint martin retrouvera
demain le dôme de la basilique
il y a deux ans et demi elle avait été
enlevée de son socle car elle menaçait
de s'effondrer
direction la dordogne pour y être
restauré avant de retrouver les sommets
demain la statue monumentale est exposée
depuis 16h aujourd'hui place châteauneuf
à tour sur place on retrouve notre
journaliste aurélie et renault aurélie
vous êtes au pied de la statue une
statue arrivée ce matin c'est bien ça
elle est arrivée ce matin par camion
donc de périgueux vous le disiez grâce à
une entreprise c'est la socra c'est
également l'entreprise qui s'est occupé
de la restauration de la statue
le camion est arrivé vers 11 heures
sorti du camion manipulation ultra
précises avec une toute petite grue
finalement elle a été placée sur le soc
elle est maintenant derrière nous toutes
les protections ont été enlevés et
maintenant on peut voir les dorures et
cette statue de saint martin rénové avec
moi serge babary bonjour monsieur le
maire bonjour quatre mois de rénovation
une statue attendu des gens qui sont
venus la voir ce soir quel est votre
sentiment ce soir enfin saint martin et
là évidemment enfin elle était très
attendue parce que demain c'est aussi un
grand jour c'est la remontée sur le dôme
de cette très belle statue qui fait 4
mètres 80 qui pèse une tonne 700 elle a
été remise en état d'une façon
magnifique on le voit toute la journée
tout l'après midi des tourangeaux sont
passés
on avait prévu des prises de photos j'ai
fait le petit celle fille de monsieur le
maire et chacun a fait sens elle fit
avec avec la statue donc c'est un moment
assez sympathique et demain la grue qui
sera présente ce sera énorme par contre
parce qu'il va falloir monter cette
statue en eau du dôme
donc demain ce sont plusieurs cérémonies
le matin une cérémonie religieuse parce
qu'on va remettre les jets raulic à
l'intérieur de la statue là où elle est
et vous avez un rôle à jouer demain on
va aller derrière lorsque la statue
monsieur le maire alors demain monsieur
le maire avec avec l'aide d'une petite
nacelle
si on le voit il ya une sorte de porte
dans laquelle je mettrai deux choses une
sorte de panneau métallique sur laquelle
indiquer la date
et puis l'objet de la rénovation et puis
un tube métallique dans lequel il y an
un parchemin qui indiquera au nom de la
municipalité
l'intérêt pour la ville de remettre à
l'honneur
la statue en place et l'intérêt pour
l'avenir de développer autour de de
saint martin de lamartine au paul
l'attractivité pour notre cité et puis
on y ajoutera dans ce tube métallique
des plans des travaux aussi bien du dôme
que de la crypte et puis le nom d le nom
des différentes entreprises sur tout ça
c'est pour les générations futures pour
celles et ceux qui un jour cendres ont
un manque ablement la statue pour la
rénover parce que c'est des savants une
centaine d'années bah écoutez ça peut
être oui 50 entre 50 et 100 tu en voilà
du coup ça nous concerne plus mais ça
sera un bon souvenir je pense de de
découvrir cela pour les tourangeaux du
futur alors beaucoup de cérémonies
demain monseigneur aubertin qui viendra
déposer des reliques également dans la
même petite trappe que la vôtre et puis
donc cette grue monumentale qui va
s'installer d'abord dans la rue
châteauneuf ensuite dans la rue des
halles ans dans l'eau on va nous en dire
un peu plus sur cette grue et sur ses
opérations avec dominique dorée qui a
piloté
on peut dire ça comme ça ces opérations
pour la ville de tours on les écoute
elle est située sur roues donc sera
situé rue des halles au pied de la
basilique
elle va étendre son bras de 70 mètres de
haut 2 longueurs passant par dessus des
habitations et va prendre en charge la
statue le pilote qui sera situé dans la
grand'rue rue des halles va travailler à
l'aveuglé il ne verra pas la statue sera
guidée par ajustement un accompagnant et
la statue une fois que ça prend en
charge va circuler rue châteauneuf à
environ un mètre de hauteur au milieu
des tourangeaux pour retrouver la rue
des halles se positionner au pied de la
basilique et ensuite la statue viendra
s'élever à 50 mètres de hauteur pour
retrouver le sommet de la basilique où
tout se passe bien il faut absolument
que le vent à une vitesse inférieure à
30 kilomètres à l'heure autrement il ne
pourra pas c'est difficile de stabiliser
la statue par le grutier puisque même à
50 mètres de hauteur il faut pouvoir
justement faire insérer la statue dans
son mât qui attend tranquillement
là où justement donc c'est au millimètre
près et donc c'est un travail très fin
et sont des gens spécialisés compétents
dans le domaine
monsieur le maire vous me confiez
pendant l'interview vous regardez la
météo depuis deux jours oui bien sûr
tout le monde est attentif à la météo
parce que on ne peut déplacer la statue
vu sa dimension son poids que avec très
peu de vent
la limite absolue ses 30 mètres seconde
donc je m'y intéresse il semblerait que
demain au moment opportun c'est à partir
de midi jusqu'à 13 heures il y aura 19
20 m seconde ce qui est tout à fait
acceptable
on pourrait annuler 6 à aller au delà si
ça va au delà ça prenne de sécurité
parce que si le c'est bon c'est bon
c'est vrai ça me rassure mais je regarde
le matin tu voyais à un petit changement
quand même dans la façon de socle et
cette statue on a changé de système
c'est ça on n'est plus sûr des écrous
qui sont vissés sur le dogme c'est une
autre technique
alors il y avait pour tenir la statue sa
stabilité
un mât métallique et qui était en fixer
sur le dôme effectivement et qu'il a
fallu scier pour permettre la descente
de la statue en février 2014
du coup cela n'existe plus puisqu'il a
été entamé et donc la méthode de
fixation est différente on va avoir un
emboîtement entre une partie qui est sur
le dôme lui-même qui a été installé sur
la nouvelle charpente d'ailleurs et puis
à l'intérieur de la statue une tige qui
va sans boiter pour tenir la stabilité
de l'ensemble
on m'a même dit que c'était des tiges en
inox c'est fait pour durer c'était mieux
que la ferraille c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
ce matin c'est mieux que la ferraille
qui avait avant merci monsieur le maire
à et puis je vous laisse admirer la
statue avec les quelques tourangeaux qui
sont là qui ont pris l'or selphy
mesdames je vous prend au dépourvu tiens
il fallait pas être là pourquoi vous
aviez envie de venir faire un petit tour
là sur la place de chatham a -
saint-martin c'est c'est c'est pour moi
un symbole de la ville de tous j'y suis
très attaché et c'est vrai qu'il me
manquait énormément
quand je regardais le dôme je voyais pas
il manquait donc là je suis super
heureuse qu'ils soient revenues on est à
peu près sûr que demain vous serez la
rue je serai là mais vous avez quand
même rentrer chez vous entre oui oui je
vois cela toute la nuit à mais vraiment
je suis heureuse qu'ils soient revenues
très heureuse
demain dans le quartier la circulation
va être un petit peu modifié évidemment
aux alentours immédiats de la basilique
la rue des halles sera fermée à la
circulation de la rue du change à la rue
de châteauneuf ça c'est de 7 heures à 18
heures et puis la place châteauneuf sera
fermée elle aussi à la circulation pour
accueillir les cérémonies auxquelles
bien sûr les tourangeaux les
tourangelles les petits les grands voit
une petite fille qui est en train de
faire un selphy avec monsieur le maire
joli sourire mademoiselle voilà demain
vous pourrez faire tout ça donc
rendez-vous dans le vieux tours au pied
de saint martin que je vous laisse
admirer voilà merci aurélie renault en
direct depuis la place châteauneuf à
tour